Okay.
What do you think is the right
answer to this one, David?
>> So what I said is that it looks like
there's a 180 degree rotation going on.
So this frame is rotated 180
degrees to get this one.
So I'm going to take C,
rotate it 180 degrees to get number six.
>> That's a fair answer, David.
Well done.
But notice there is another
possible answer here.
Two is also a possible answer.
Why is two a possible answer?
Because one can imagine that
B is really a reflection of
A across a vertical axis, and
that way if we think of a vertical
axis on C, then two will be the
deflection/ of C on the vertical axis.
So both two and
six are good answers here.
And one question will then become,
which one do humans pick,
do they pick six or do they pick two?
And second which one
should an AI program pick?
Six or two, and
how would you make sure that the AI
program picks two or six, and
if you are thinking I am going to give
you the answer, sorry to disappoint you.
I'm going to leave this as a puzzle for
you.
Your AI program will
address this problem